foreign
California hi Alexandra how are you
how are you Dave and Christina hi hi
better than we deserve Merry Christmas
how can we help
hi um so basically I just wanted to know
what you think is the best time when
dating like
um is to ask about finances like
financial goals debts income and things
like that
are you currently dating someone right
now
no
I like this question and so it's like
for future person that you meet
yeah and just like when you're on a
dating like you know when you're meeting
new new people and stuff like that
that's a great question Dave I'm curious
about your take because I haven't dated
in 50 years I don't have any idea
well what's funny is I've only had one
date for 50 years
what's funny too though is like we've
had so many people come through recently
on the debt-free stage that said that
they talked about you on their first
date yeah that has come up I don't know
that that's your recommendation no it's
not I can't I can't really say Ramsey is
Romance I'm just it just doesn't scream
Romance
um maybe for grown-ups I don't know but
uh oh my gosh I don't um
so I
trying to think how how I would coach
like one of my kids
or something because what you're looking
for when you're dating is
um I mean you're either just out there
goofing off or you're actually looking
for someone to marry right and so
um
if you have Financial things or anything
in your life values wise
you should have a lot of things that are
deal breakers
uh
maybe it's not romantic maybe it's
efficiency but I'd want to get to the
deal breakers fairly
quick just to not waste time
I don't know I'm making this up on the
spot on it what do you think Christina
so when my husband and I were dating we
went to this church service together at
one point where the pastor gave us a
challenge and he said if you are single
or if you're dating right now if you
start dating someone I want you to go
home tonight and sit down with that
person and lay everything on the table
like lay out all your drama lay out any
type of baggage you have anything hidden
your financial stuff this was like three
weeks into dating for us because they
were like if like you said if that's
something you can't handle it's like you
know the baggage early on like you know
early on whether or not that person has
a history whether they have like things
that are deal breakers for you so we
literally went home that night we went
over actually I think we did a like a
coffee house or something and we sat
down and we said we said okay here's the
stuff here's my stuff here's my junk can
you handle it and obviously near nearly
15 years later here we are we're still
good but I think that's an important
practice to kind to go you know I don't
want to find out a year into dating when
I'm already in love that they have
something that I can't tolerate okay I'm
here's an interesting idea I'm just I'm
making this up on the spot I do this a
lot on this show y'all don't know that
but um okay the four things we do know
data the four things that if you're in
agreement on these four things you have
a very high likelihood of your marriage
not only lasting but prospering money
religion kids whether to have them and
how to treat them and dealing with the
um
in-laws
the extended family because in every
family there's crazy and if you think
there's not it's you so
um that you know that that you need to
know how to deal with crazy because
crazy's out there somewhere and um so
we're gonna if you can deal with the
four things extended family kids
religion
and money if you're in agreement on
those you will prosper so I would want
to
at some point discuss all of those
things or sooner rather than later but
first date might be weird you know but
um I mean like you know he's going to
pay for your dinner with a credit card
and you go into freak out mode or
something it's over it's covered you're
an idiot what are you crazy yeah that's
it it's over we're done wait a minute we
didn't even start okay but yeah
so I don't know what what are you
thinking Alexandra
um I mean I I know that a birthday of
course I'm not going to be like well how
much debt are you in but I've always
just like okay well as a second and
third like you said with time I'm like
well I don't want to waste each other's
time like I want us to be on the same
page with like financial goals like what
we want in the future and things like
that so
um I'm thinking like
um what Christina said with
um you know like a week two weeks you
know putting it all on the table like
hey it seems like we really like each
other like let's really like what what
are they
what are my non-negotiables okay and I'd
want to know those
um you know like if you never want to
have kids and this person wants to have
17 kids
that's probably a deal breaker you know
for most people right
um and it you know if you uh you know
absolutely cannot stand the idea of
being in debt and they think that
um you should go borrow 10 million
dollars and buy investment real estate
off of tick tock suggestions
um then you know you probably don't have
a fit right and so if you're on Extremes
in other words that's going to wake you
up
um you know your spiritual walk would be
a big one that'd be a big one
um as a deal breaker because that's
going to inform almost every other area
of your life
and so
um you know if they're go if they are of
a different religion or no religion
they're atheist or whatever that's going
to inform that belief system and it is a
belief system either way is going to
inform parenting it's going to inform
communication it's going to inform
everything how you treat each other the
whole bit and so yeah that's very
interesting but yeah I I it does feel
like that
um
uh uh you're not just data is you're not
rec if you're not doing recreational
dating okay if you're dating for the
purpose of uh what you would have called
in the 1950s courting right or something
like that for the purpose of looking for
a mate to marry then you're you're going
to get there sooner than later on all
the non-negotiables and money would just
be one of them
well and I think it's better to get
there sooner rather than later of course
not awkwardly on the first date but
sooner rather than later so you're not
wasting time because it's like if you
get to eight months and it's a
non-negotiable that sucks the 17 kids if
you don't realize that until you're
dating some of these people are putting
like FPU graduate on their dating
website the thing like oh you know or
like I do the Ramsey stuff or something
like that and so it's like oh I can't
stand those people I'm they're all a
cult and so I'm not going out with that
person right that makes sense I mean
that's at least it's a filter yeah I was
gonna say it filters it yeah
so um I mean we we get Negative press
sometimes and so but we kind of like it
because it's a filter because at least
people know who we are and you go I
don't like that okay then you wouldn't
want to be over here you know it's
kind of a deal breaker the same kind of
a date you know different different
things so
um yeah that's that's very interesting
though maybe maybe we should have a
reason dating service we have have had
lots of people request a Ramsey dating
service so many so that we actually
considered it and said no
whoa yeah it comes up all the time
that's just weird but yeah but it does
come up it comes up a lot so uh there we
go and um oh my goodness wow yeah that's
uh yeah
it's interesting I feel like it is kind
of nice to have those filters because it
is such a different world of dating even
15 years for me and my husband and you
and Sharon it's like with the internet
and so many filters and being able to
choose things that's like being able to
just like have that information up front
would be nice for it to be like hey I'm
debt free or hey you know I see this one
like yeah I'm not the dead is a filter
like a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt it's kind of like
saying I've got two children
you would want to know that
you would yeah fairly quickly you know
yeah and then you get to decide if you
want to go forward with two children or
four hundred thousand either one I mean
that's part of the process